serge dit de moi quel effet ça vous fait
d'être acteur je vous dirais je veux
dire par là ça vous fait plaisir ça vous
pensé à devenir célèbre plage parce que
vous avez je me suis déjà ça
il est l'objet
je vais tuer une stabilité de dire ça je
me dis faire parce que c'est pas trés
c'est pas très directe comme réponse je
viens s'est fait plaisir à déjouer une
stress sont sur ces faux jeton pour vous
mais pour le directeur
ça fait plaisir oui ça va me changer
ils disent qu'ils tournent vers donc est
ce que c'est ça on a dit que vous avez
la physique ingrat
moi je ne trouve pas ma femme beaucoup
on vous dit ça
s'agirait de définir ce que c'est qu'un
gratitude alors et moi j'ai une trop